-This is very exciting.
I love this.
You and Nick have
written a book together.
-Yes.
-"Greatest Love Story --"
What is it?
"Greatest Love Story Ever Told."
-"Ever Told," Seth. Ever.
-And, now, I know Nick
has written books before.
-Yes.
-But this is your first time
writing one with him.
Was this his idea?
Whose idea was it
to write one together?
-It was completely my idea.
-Okay.
-I had to talk him into it,
twist his arm.
And then, finally,
he was really into it.
So, what we did was --
we were on the road
with my band, actually.
And, so, we were just in
various hotels
and we'd be laying in bed.
He's not normally allowed to
speak to me when we're in bed.
Touching only, no speaking.
But I made an exception
and I said, "Hey --"
'Cause we already had
our chapter ideas.
I said, "Hey, why don't we
knock out a chapter."
So he pulled out his phone,
turned on the tape recorder,
and then we just start
talking about, you know,
families or religion or
whatever the chapter was about
and whatever the topic was.
And then that's what
the book is.
It's kind of, like,
interview-magazine style.
It's just us having
real conversations.
-That's fantastic.
-It's so cool. It's fun.
-One thing we have in common,
which I always forget, is --
we both went to
Northwestern University.
-I know. I can't believe that.
I always forget that.
-But you did not stay
till the end.
-No. I'm a college dropout.
-You're a college dropout,
but the story --
-You said that very politely.
-Yes.
Well, because it wasn't
like you didn't have the grades.
You had something better
than college.
-I was doing -- I got a show
downtown that went pro.
And, so, I went back for
my junior year,
and I was having
a hard time doing
eight shows a week downtown
and doing, you know,
like, a full load of classes.
-Yeah.
-So, I went in to talk to
the dean, to get her advice,
and she was like, "Drop out."
I was like, "That is not
what I was expecting.
And she said, "Well, you're
doing what you want to do,
so who cares?"
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah.
-That really speaks to
the school that they realized,
"We don't have anything
else to teach you.
You're already there."
Well, you've certainly done
the school proud.
-You too.
-Thank you very much.
It's always so great to see you.
Thanks for being here, Megan.
-Thank you.